so Amy after being contacted by peter
and fran and getting the go-ahead to go
down to arkansas what were some of your
first steps in organizing you know
people that you would contact first and
how you would sort of organize your
research well before i actually got the
go-ahead actually did my own research
for about six months and really studied
everything that had been done at that
point and I'd so so when I actually did
start filming it was mostly just going
through what was presented in the trial
and just knocking on people's doors and
trying to kind of rebuild the picture
and you mentioned in a prior interview
that throughout the town there was
almost a cancer that sort of had spread
because people were so divided and it
was so emotionally charged how are you
approaching possible interview subjects
knowing that you could be the recipient
of their anger or maybe they wouldn't
want to return your calls yeah you never
really knew what was going to happen
when you had knock on someone's door
often it was just the person had moved
and three other people have moved in and
then you had to kind of go and try to
find them somewhere else and just kind
of follow the steps but it was it's a
really sad town and the fact that so
much was unresolved just it was almost
like everyone left and so you had like
this new kind of migration of people and
it was just it's just there's just this
real sadness about west memphis arkansas
and it just kind of has it hasn't
recovered was there a lot of hearsay
that you were dealing with that maybe
they more facts but there was a lot of
hearsay from past people that live there
yeah and it was it was more than that
because they hear the whole thing was
based on hearsay so then it was hearsay
three times removed so there were just
so many crazy stories that just you know
you couldn't really you kept thinking oh
maybe this is it but then it was just
like another rabbit hole so and what
would you recommend to other
documentarians on staying emotionally
removed from their quote unquote
subjects or is that one of the risk
that you take with documentary
filmmaking is just becoming immersed in
their lives yeah I'm not that good at
that so I don't know I definitely feel
like you have to be so present and it is
important to you know to have your
boundaries and everything but it's it I
think it's so important that people know
that you care about them and that you're
there to try to find the truth so I'm
probably the wrong person to ask about
that what do you think people will take
away or what you want them to take away
from west of Memphis about not only
these powerful stories but about
groupthink and scapegoating because in
light of bullying in recent years it
seems like this is a very hot topic in
terms of well west of Memphis I feel
like this this this case and this story
is probably the worst injustice in US
history it's like something that I think
we can learn from so I would hope that
people would walk away from this film
feeling that they can they can look at
all these aspects of this case to
hopefully not do this again but I also
feel like it shows the fundamental
issues in our system I mean due to the
fact that we have elected politicians in
our justice system i think is the
biggest problem and we would hope that
maybe there would be some reform in that
regard and the fact that there's been so
much misconduct on the level the
officials and nobody is paying the price
for that